the way you write the language is like
more heightened sometimes almost I love
to throw in a 50 cent word here and
there and then you have to call 50 cent
congratulations on what I'm calling a
demented woman's magazine it's like they
let you resurrect McCall's from the 90s
and write whatever the hell you wanted
about the book being out I love how hard
it is it is hard and sturdy you could go
you can whack some you could knock
somebody out with it
yeah I've been kind of working on my
posture which is the nice it's a
multi-purpose tool it's a weapon it's a
balance tool you can gather of like a
charcuterie on it yeah if you get two of
them it's a doorstop yeah yeah or you
know you could just read it as the
intended purpose is the first dragon
bullet you won't want to use as a
doorstop
exactly there's talked to me about how
this idea came about well I've always
wanted to learn how to read and write so
this was like a passion project of mine
that came to fruition which is usually
something that I don't experience in
terms of goals or ambition home came to
us was like if you learned to read him
right we'll pay you some money and I was
like yeah I'm ready to get hooked honey
hooked on phonics phonics is the first
thing she has not been hooked on we
really wanted to be like Dean Koontz
nice try well here's how you write a
book I better don't put this in school
at um curriculums this will probably
take the place of Catcher in the Rye
because I think Biddle's that only has
one jerk off mention and this is yeah
yeah many yeah yeah I can't wait to see
it in a school library let me tell you
this story when I was in sixth grade I
had to read a book about a Native
American a person and I picked a book
called Shoshone girl about a girl who
was Shoshone right read the book top to
bottom nothing ever happened this book
was called shoeshine girl and I finished
that book and said I read a book about a
shoeshine girl
there is no Shoshone Native American
women in this I was like you know I was
in sixth grade I'm busy did you know I
didn't know how to spell Shoshone and I
read Wow and I'm reading the book at no
point we were like she's
shining a lot of shoes and doing nothing
about her culture up here I'm not
because I don't have a single shine shoe
in my house so I got nothing on that
boat
anyway that's more of a personal story
that's a great personal strike little
anecdote there this book why was it
important to insult the reader from the
jump the introduction says you're
reading this book and you're dumb
well because listen you have to install
a hierarchy right away so that they
there is a ladder to climb that there's
somewhere to go and I believe the quote
you're speaking to it's related to a
John Waters quote where he says if you
go home with somebody and they don't
have books don't become and I always
found that advice to be rather
incomplete because having books doesn't
mean reading books right and half even
owning books doesn't make you smart
because if you bought this book thank
you smart makes you desperate for
guidance you may or may not get at the
end of reading it are some pop culture
confessions in here that are a little
wild like the fact that Trixie has never
seen the television series friends oh
and thank God because it sucks well
that's what I learned from crotchy his
book I said because she talks about the
Rachel in the hair section yeah how that
was a cultural impact you know Conte was
like you're missing nothing it's people
now are friends you avoided it I feel
like it's permeated the culture so
heavily that it's like you have to have
seen at least one episode
oh no honestly it's a hermit she takes
hermit like to a level like a previously
unexplored level like she will
completely just be watcher the only show
I watched was drag race and then I was
on it enough times it yeah I mean I
loved the friends opening song yeah who
does how does it go do-do-do-do-do knee
that's it right that's exactly the
starring Mariska Hargitay has on order
special friends unit
you bring up drag race should you if the
book is not overtly about your
experience on drag race but there are
mentions of it on a take away I thought
was interesting was that sometimes your
friends in the work room while you're
making the show do not translate to
friendships outside of the show Charlie
yeah when you don't have your phone and
when you don't have internet and you are
literally forced to do nothing but
relate and work with one another in a
high-pressure situation that none of you
have ever experienced before in about
which you have a lot of expectations you
know going forward you if you tend to
just kind of latch on and of course
we're all gay so it's like room but
mostly April Ford's real er
relationships without the internet okay
boomer yeah but but but but but the
thing is though then you get off the
show cuz I mean two days into the
competition you're like and then you get
home a week later you're like what do I
even like yeah we're one of the most
celebrated friendships in modern media
and we won't even close on drag race we
were there almost the same amount of
time and like yeah yeah yeah we became
friends afterwards I mean I always
closer to ginger and I don't I haven't
talked to her weeks not even up she's
still alive her phone's turned off yeah
you know you know Florida International
rates are so unfair this is America land
of the free home with the fat people did
you tell the story in the book of you
went and like to go visit somebody you
thought was your close friend from the
show and spend some time with them
outside the show and it was like this is
not it who was that I won't say but it
was a it was I think it was just like it
was the setting it was like oh when you
were out of the workroom like you know
you see how somebody lives we see like
their friends and like you see you smell
different smells and it was just jarring
you know it was every friendship seemed
really instantly important because
you're the you're the only lifeline each
other has you know
let's talk to the cameraman do you and I
mean yeah and I had to quit smoking for
a year and a half and ginger Minj she
got me hooked back on cigarettes within
three days makes it look so cool I never
find out what did you learn about each
other in this process because writing a
book is a different animal than filming
a TV show or filming a web series this
is a lot more back and forth yeah I
don't want to be cornball I mean I know
that you're good-looking and dragged but
some of these pictures really like kind
of got me together like that is that -
that's my Nordstrom ad minority dad
don't you see that on the on a big
Nordstrom I see it on a Nordstrom Rack
not all right he means that were hanging
on the rack and I mean and we are
beautiful but I kind of forget look at
that look at that did you each learn
anything about yourselves through the
writing process oh absolutely it was not
I wasn't returned to me I would like to
return her no I learned that I was
nothing new was learned but one thing
was would bluntly reinforced which was
that I am categorically undeniably
pathetically the most egregious
procrastinator like it is is
breathtaking how I will wait to the last
minute and then I will dangle off the
edge of that last minute until I'm about
to die before I have a pinky toe
yeah just I mean it is it's just
diabolical I don't know why I can't just
work you know but here we are in Trixie
what did you learn about yourself just
in a beautiful and intelligent all right
I got to wrap things up here who are you
rooting for on all-stars five and why is
it shakily I'm gonna say what we're all
thinking
we're all watching drag race going I'm
so happy I'm not competing in shakily
yeah yeah I mean shade my new shows
together since way back you know she's
one of those drag queens never looked
bad kicking raps you can sing
I mean it's excellent it's not just by
excellence it's drag excellence
it is dragon eye I will however say
something controversial and very brave
I'm actually rooting for you to be this
I will also accept yeah because I I'm
telling you and you know your drag race
gets a clarified down to little moments
and sound bites that resonate and and
once the Queen is off the show we don't
you you know parroted back to you
ad nauseam forever that thermostat line
from the snatch game of love how would
you keep me warm at night I would
centrally walk to the thermostat imeem I
thought she should have won the
challenge and I was on the phone with
her the other day and she was doing the
voice even better than she does on the
show because she's so good at it and
it's just I don't know I love to watch
her she's been I wanna I wanna run every
season she's just you know I think the
game of all-stars is like be proud of
who you might lose to and you proud to
list a shade jew-jew yeah you know like
there's so many good options to lose to
me like yeah yeah I lost like when I
almost I mean I could have lost it
Kennedy would've been like yeah I'm only
human
yeah it's gonna be Davenport yeah you're
not loser because you lose to you know
somebody amazing comadre
right all right well thank you guys any
last words about the book any plugs you
want to make about the book you have it
on hardcover we have it in eBook and we
even did an audiobook of our real voices
yeah and if you have a Vitamix at home
you can blend it into a nice shape
[Music]